escribe las siguientes fracciones como
fracciones cuyo denominador es un mínimo
común denominador y las fracciones son
dos octavos y cinco sextos y bueno
escribir estas fracciones de tal forma
que su denominador sea su mínimo común
denominador es muy útil cuando vamos a
sumar o restar las fracciones y resulta
que el mínimo común denominador de estas
fracciones va a ser simplemente el
mínimo común múltiplo de los dos
denominadores que déjame lo escribo por
acá ok el mínimo común denominador de
estas dos fracciones es exactamente
igual al mínimo común múltiplo de 8 y 6
ok y cómo calculamos el mínimo común
múltiplo de 8 y 6 pues hay muchas formas
la primera que se nos puede ocurrir es
tal cual ponernos a escribir los
múltiplos de 8 y ponernos a escribir los
múltiplos de 6 y fijarnos cuál es el
mínimo que tienen en común y bueno pues
hagamos eso hay otras formas de las que
les voy a hablar después pero empecemos
por eso
y pues los múltiplos de 6 son pues un
múltiplo de 6 es el mismo 6 que es 6 por
1 el siguiente sería 6 por 2 que es 12 y
luego stage por 3 18 6 por 4 24 y
después 30 36 42 48 y nos podemos seguir
así de hecho puedes llegar lejísimos
pero yo creo que el máximo común
múltiplo entre 8 y 6 ya se encuentra en
esta lista ahora escribamos los
múltiplos del 88 por 18 8 por 2 16 8 por
3 24 8 por 4 32 a pero aquí ya tenemos
un número en común aquí si se fijan aquí
el 24 ya aparecen las dos listas así es
que el 24 es un múltiplo de 6 y el 24 es
un múltiplo de 8 y por aquí yo no veo
ninguna repetición en este pedazo no veo
ninguna repetición así es que este es
el mínimo de los múltiplos comunes a 68
ok entonces el mínimo común múltiplo
entre 8 y 6 es igual a 24 hay otras
formas de hacerlo por ejemplo podemos
factorizar en primos el 6 es la
multiplicación de 2 por 3 y el 8 es la
multiplicación de 2 por 4 y el 4 pues
también es la multiplicación de 2 por 2
entonces para construir el mínimo común
múltiplo de esta forma pues lo que
tenemos que hacer es encontrar un número
que tenga todos estos factores primos o
sea tenemos que buscar un número que
tenga dentro de sus factores el número 3
y 12 que además tenga dentro de sus
factores primos 3 12 eso sea 12 por este
otro 2 y otro 2 y bueno claro que puedes
ir a buscarlo hasta que lo encuentres o
podemos construirlo o sea podemos
simplemente agarrar y poner ok tiene que
tener un 3 y un 2 o sea multiplicamos 3
por 2
vamos a multiplicarlo por los factores
primos que faltan del 8 aquí pues ya
tenemos 12 que podemos asociarlo con
este 2 y entonces nada más nos falta
multiplicarlo por otros 2 2 es todo este
pedazo así que esta multiplicación este
número sea un múltiplo de 8 y este
pedazo por acá hace que este número sea
un múltiplo de 6 y cuál es este número
pues es 3 por 2 6 por 2 12 por 2 24 24
mira nos quedó lo mismo en los dos lados
o sea que estamos muy bien y entonces
pues ya que tenemos cuál va a ser el
mínimo común denominador de estas dos
fracciones pues ahora tenemos que
convertir las fracciones de tal forma
que tengan este denominador entonces
tenemos dos octavos y eso lo vamos a
convertir en una fracción que tiene como
denominador 24 ahora para que esta
fracción se exactamente igual a esta
fracción lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar arriba y abajo sea numerador
y denominador por la misma cosa
en realidad estamos multiplicando por un
1 y entonces no estamos afectando la
fracción ok como podemos ver aquí si
esta es la parte del número que
representa el 8 entonces tenemos que
multiplicar la por lo que sobra para que
nos dé 24 que hay entonces para pasar de
aquí a que tuvimos que multiplicar por 3
entonces aquí vamos a tener que
multiplicar por 3 y 2 por 3 son 6
entonces 2 octavos es igual a 6 24 años
que lo podemos ver como 2 x 3 entre 8
por 3 y tenemos que hacer lo mismo con 5
sextos nada más que necesitamos más
espacio
así es que voy a recorrer esto para
quedar 5 sextos lo queremos escribir
como una fracción cuyo denominador es 24
24 es un múltiplo de 6 y nada más
tenemos que multiplicar el 6 por 2 por 2
o sea por 4 entonces aquí tenemos que
multiplicar 6 por 4 entonces aquí el 5
también lo tenemos que multiplicar por 4
o sea 5 x 4 20 5 x 4 / 6 x 4
y listo dos octavos es igual a 624 abós
y cinco sextos es igual a 2024 abós
entonces este es el resultado estas son
las fracciones con mínimo común
denominador entre ellas y bueno ahorita
podríamos restar sumar y hacer un montón
de cosas pero como esto es lo que nos
pidieron aquí nos vamos a detener